RONALD SMITH: Now you may
remember the
other day when I
derived how planets
retain their atmospheres, I made
a list of what planets
and moons we expect to
have atmospheres
and which ones don't.
Right at the bottom of that
list, of the ones that we
thought would have atmosphere,
it's kind of the
last one was Titan.
As it turns out, we have a
lecture today in the geology
department on the atmosphere
of Titan.
If any of you are interested
in seeing that,
that's at 4:00 p.m.
in Kline geology 123,
on the first floor,
next building over.
So stop in there if you want to
learn about the atmosphere
of that particular object.
Questions on any of that?
OK.
Now let's think about what
happened last time.
We went over quite a bit of
material, quantitative
material, it had to do largely
with the perfect gas law and
the concept of pressure.
Are there any questions on the
perfect gas law or those
derivations that we
did last time?
I went through them relatively
quickly and I don't think we
spent quite enough time,
perhaps, to get
your questions answered.
Anything on the perfect
gas law?
Remember we found that when
we're using the p equals rho
RT formula the perfect gas
law that we use mostly in
atmospheric sciences, that
gas constant R is not the
universal gas constant it's a
gas constant for the specific
gas that you are using.
So that's kind of the one trick
to remember when you're
using that.
We went on to do a little
discussion on buoyancy.
If you have a blob of air
that's at a different
temperature than the adjacent
air, we argued that it's
pressure would equilibrate, but
that would leave it --if
it has a different temperature
that would leave it with a
different density.
And if it has a different
density then it's going to be
buoyant and either tending
to accelerate upwards or
accelerate downwards.
So that was a nice application
of the perfect gas law to
understand what begins to get
the air moving in the Earth's
atmosphere or any atmosphere.
It has to do with differential
heating.
If you can heat air differently
so it has
different temperatures, then
these density differences
acting through gravity, through
buoyancy, will begin
to get the are moving.
So simple but very fundamental
concept.
We'll be coming back to that
over and over again.
Anything on that?
OK.
Well then at the end, we talked
about the vertical
structure of density
and pressure.
And I'll just review
that very quickly.
Both density and pressure have
a vertical distribution that
is close to the exponential
function.
So for example, mass density rho
as a function of altitude
is given by the density at sea
level, I guess I'll call that
SL, times e to the minus
z over H sub s.
And the same thing
for pressure.
Pressure as a function of
altitude is given by the
pressure at sea level
times e to the minus
height over H sub s.
H sub s is the scale height.
I'm going to try to give you
a word definition of it.
It's the height interval over
which the pressure or density
decreases by a factor
e to the minus one.
In other words, when this
quantity in the exponent is
one, that's what we're
talking about.
When you've gone up one scale
height, z is equal to H sub s,
and you've decreased the
pressure by that amount.
Now, e, you may recall--
the mathematical constant e--
is 2.71828, et cetera.
So e to the minus one
is one over that.
It's about 0.368 and so on,
which we often round off and
say, well, that's
about one third.
So here's what we say.
When you go up one scale height,
the pressure has
dropped to one third of
what it was at the
bottom of that interval.
So mark off three equal parts.
Roughly, that's what it's
dropped to when you go up one
scale height.
When you go up another scale
height, another--
let me remind you, scale height
can be computed from RT
over g, and for Earth, that's
about 8,400 meters.
So when I go up another 8,400
meters and mark off that into
three parts, it drops by
about another third--
another 2/3 to a value one third
of what it was at the
bottom of that interval.
And then that just repeats.
You see, that gives you a curve
that approaches zero but
never reaches it.
And that's the nature
of the atmosphere.
The density gets less and less,
but it never actually
reaches zero because of the
nature of this proportional
decrease for each scale height
that you go up in the
atmosphere.
So there is no such thing as a
top of the atmosphere, where
you could find a level where
there's atmosphere below and
none above.
There is no such place.
Eventually, of course, you're
in outer space, but even in
outer space, there are a
few molecules up there.
So that would just be this curve
continuing up quite a
bit further.
Are there any questions on this
concept of a scale height?
It's the best way we have of
describing how the pressure
and density change
with height.
It's a rather smooth curve.
Sometimes it's not exactly
like this, but generally,
that's a pretty good
representation of how it works.
Yes.
STUDENT: In the equation
up on the scale
height, what is the R?
PROFESSOR: So this
is the gas constant for
the gas in question.
I'll call it the specific
gas constant.
This is the temperature
of the atmosphere.
We have to use a single value
for that, which is a bit of an
approximation.
And then this is the surface
gravity for the planet.
For Earth, you know what
that is, 9.81.
Now, this will be different
on different planets.
For example, if I had a
different gas, then the gas
constant would be different.
If I had a different
temperature,
the T would be different.
And all the other planets, of
course, will have their own
values for surface gravity.
So as you go from planet to
planet, you'll find this value
will change.
For some atmospheres,
it'll be larger.
it'll be smaller.
A larger value of scale height
means that the atmosphere
decreases its density more
slowly as you go up.
You have a deeper atmosphere.
A smaller value for scale height
means pressure and
density decrease more rapidly
as you go up.
You have a shallower
or a thinner--
an atmosphere that's
not as deep.
Any questions on that?
Yes.
STUDENT: For Earth, what
temperature are you using?
PROFESSOR: So you
can back it out from this, but
I think I used the surface
temperature, 288 Kelvin, which
probably, as I'll show
in a minute, is
not the best choice.
It probably would've been better
to use some kind of
average temperature all up and
down through the atmosphere.
So you're going to get a
slightly different number here
depending what temperature
you use there.
But for that, remember you're
going to use 8,314 divided by
the average molecular weight
of air, which is 29.
That's a mixture of nitrogen,
which is 28, and
oxygen, which is 32.
29 is a good molecular weight
for that mixture we call air.
Other questions on this?
So we did an example, and
you can do others.
Just imagine you're on a
mountaintop or you're flying
in an airplane at a
certain altitude.
Put that altitude into this
formula, and you can quickly
compute what the pressure and
density are going to be at
that level.
Very convenient, because
that kind of question
arises all the time.
Now, while density and pressure
have a pretty
featureless, smooth decrease
with altitude, temperature is
very different.
So let's talk about the
temperature profile in the
atmosphere.
And again, I'll make a plot of
temperature on this axis.
And altitude, I'll use z
for altitude going up.
This axis isn't exactly to
scale, but I'll put some
numbers on it to help you out.
The temperature of the Earth's
atmosphere is very curious.
It has a shape like this.
The average surface temperature
at the surface,
288 Kelvin.
Mentioned that.
It drops to approximately 200
Kelvin at an altitude of about
10 kilometers.
At about 50 kilometers, it comes
back to about what it
was before--
not exactly, but about that--
then it decreases again about
down to 200 at about 90
kilometers.
And then it gets quite warm
above that, higher than at the
surface of the Earth.
Now, this temperature, though,
changes quite a bit between
day and night as it gets heated
by the Sun and then
cools at night.
Well, actually, that
happens at Earth.
Right down at the surface
of the Earth,
there's a bit of a diurnal--
we use the word "diurnal" to
indicate a day-to-night
fluctuation.
Of course, that happens
right at the surface
of the Earth, too.
There's a bit of a diurnal
cycle in temperature.
And of course, these
temperatures will be changing
also with weather patterns,
with seasons, and so on.
So I don't want to indicate
that that's fixed, but
generally, it looks something
like that.
Now, this is really important.
And the fact that the atmosphere
is layered in
temperature gives us the basis
for classifying these
different altitudes.
And I'm going to give you the
standard classification then.
This layer, from the surface
of the Earth up to about 10
kilometers, where the
temperature decreases with
altitude, that's called
the troposphere.
It's defined in just that way.
It's the lowest layer starting
at the Earth's surface, and
the temperature decreases
with altitude.
When the temperature turns
around and starts increasing
again, that's the
stratosphere.
Then there's the mesosphere.
And finally, up here, this
is the thermosphere.
Now, these names do
have some meaning.
They're not just drawn
out of a hat.
"Tropos" comes from a Greek
word meaning "turning." In
this case, it implies that that
layer of the atmosphere
is turning over quite a lot.
And we'll see why that is.
There's quite a bit of
convection turning that air
over in the troposphere.
So "tropos" or "tropo" does
have some meaning.
"Strato" also, the root comes
from the word "layers." And
here the air does not
turn over very much.
It lies there more or less
in quiet layers.
It may be blowing very fast,
but you don't have strong,
active overturning
or convection.
Mesosphere, well, it's in
the middle somewhere.
And then thermosphere is
the hottest layer.
You can use the name to remind
yourself of that.
We have names also for these
boundaries between the
different layers.
The boundary at the top of the
troposphere is the tropopause.
And then the stratopause, the
mesopause, and there is no top
to the thermosphere.
Now, this is an interesting
puzzle.
Why would the Earth's
temperature
structure look like that?
Anybody have an idea, a
suggestion of why you might
have that kind of an odd
temperature structure in the
Earth's atmosphere?
STUDENT: In the stratosphere, it
tends to start off cooling
it more because of the ozone
on top of the stratosphere.
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So how does the ozone
do that, though?
The ozone is playing
a role here.
What does it do?
STUDENT: It absorbs the
Sun's UV energy.
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
So if you--
but that's exactly right.
Now, let me back up.
If I moved my hand across this
table and I found some hot
spots and some cool spots, you
would probably guess that
there's a little heat source
under each of the hot spots.
And that's exactly right.
So there's three temperature
maxima here.
And we have identified three
sources of heat for each of
the maxima.
And this one has to
do with ozone
absorbing ultraviolet light.
So let me lay that out a little
more systematically.
If you look at the light that
comes from the Sun and I plot
intensity versus wavelength, it
has kind of a bell-shaped
curve like this.
The Sun emits at all
wavelengths--
very short, intermediate,
very long--
but most of its radiation
is centered
somewhere close to about--
well, I'll put some numbers
on here in just a minute.
In fact, let me do that.
So there's a range here from 0.4
to 0.7 microns that's what
we call the visible part
of the spectrum.
That's the part of the spectrum
that the human eye is
sensitive to.
To the right of that, at longer
wavelengths, we call
that the infrared part
of the spectrum.
And we break that further up
into the near-infrared, NIR,
and then the middle-
or the long-wave
infrared further out.
And the same thing
to the left.
At shorter wavelengths, we have
the ultraviolet, which
I'll abbreviate UV. And the
nearest part of that is the
NUV, the near ultraviolet.
And then you have the middle
and the far ultraviolet.
Way out here, you have x-rays
as part of that spectrum.
So the Sun is radiating like
this, and those photons, that
radiation, approaches the Earth
and hits the atmosphere.
What's going to happen?
Well, it turns out that the
x-rays and the far-ultraviolet
are absorbed by the first
molecules that they encounter.
So let me try to
put that here.
I'll have a double arrow
coming down, and we'll
indicate that there's absorption
of the x-rays and
the far UV, FUV.
These other wavelengths--
the near ultraviolet, the
visible, the near-infrared,
the far-infrared--
they are not absorbed
at that level.
They come streaming
on through.
So I'll draw another arrow here
to indicate what happens
to the near UV, NUV. It gets
absorbed by the ozone that's
in the stratosphere.
Ozone is a molecule.
You know it's O3.
It has three oxygen atoms
tied together like that.
And that molecular structure
happens to be able to absorb
near ultraviolet rays.
So that provides a heat source
which can act here.
Everything else--
the visible, the near-infrared,
and much of the
far-infrared--
come streaming all the way
down through and gets
absorbed, finally, by
the ground, by the
Earth's surface itself.
The atmosphere doesn't absorb
it at all, but the Earth's
surface does.
And then, the Earth's surface
heats up and passes that heat
back to the atmosphere by
conduction, and then pretty
quickly, by convection as well
to heat up the lower part of
the atmosphere.
The fact that some of this heat
is transported upwards by
convection is maybe already
beginning to explain why this
is the troposphere, why it has
to do with mixing, because
that heat is being put
into the bottom.
If you put a pan of water on
the stove and heat it up,
you're putting the heat
in at the bottom.
And of course, that pot of water
is going to convect,
because you are making less
dense water at the bottom.
And then those buoyancy forces
we were talking about are
going to make those rise.
And before long, you're
going to have a
convection cell going on.
Questions on this?
So, to understand this, we need
to understand the nature
of the radiation coming
from the sun.
We'll be coming back to this
when we talk about the Earth's
energy budget, which we'll
do in just about a week.
So it won't be long
before we'll be
revisiting this subject.
Any questions on it?
Now, you probably have a pretty
good gut feeling for
distances measured horizontally
on the Earth's surface.
You know how long a football
field is, 100 yards.
You know how long a mile is.
But I think most of us, unless
we're pilots or whatever, we
don't have a good feeling for
distances in the vertical.
So I want to supplement the
simple diagram by just a few
facts that you may already know,
but maybe you don't.
For example, Mount Washington,
which is the highest mountain
in New England, is
1,917 meters.
That is to say, about
two kilometers.
So where does that lie
on this diagram?
It's about there somewhere.
Mount McKinley, sometimes
called
Denali, is 6,196 meters.
Let's round that off and
call it six kilometers.
That's the highest mountain
in North America,
and it's about there.
Mount Everest is 8,848 meters.
Let's round that off and call
it nine kilometers, that's
somewhere about here.
So that gives you some sense
of vertical scale on this
tropopause business, right?
Some mountains--
in fact, this is not always
the same altitude.
It varies quite a bit.
Sometimes the tropopause could
be as low as six kilometers on
occasion, in which case, if
you were standing even on
Mount McKinley, on such a day,
you would be standing in the
stratosphere.
On other days, though, on a
typical day, on the top of
Mount McKinley, you'd be
standing in the upper part of
the troposphere.
On Mount Everest, it's going
to be a near thing.
You're going to be
the stratosphere
quite often, actually.
Now a few other things.
If you fly around a little
bit with aircraft--
how many have been in
a light plane, like
a Piper or a Cessna?
Anybody?
Remember what it was?
Remember how high you got?
13,000 feet.
That's a good number.
That's about as high as
you can get in those
really small airplanes.
Now that's feet, so I divide
that by three, I get something
like four kilometers.
That's about as high as
one of those little
airplanes can get.
And so that's about here.
If you've flown recently in
a commuter aircraft--
just flying from one city to
a close one nearby, you're
probably going to be at about
20,000 feet, and what that's
going to be, maybe
seven kilometers.
Remember, aviation today, and
always, still uses feet as its
distance unit.
They don't use the
metric system.
So you always have to go back,
when you're talking to a
pilot, you've got to tell him
how high you want to fly in
feet, because that's the only
thing he understands.
But then, for the scientist,
you've got to quickly convert
that to meters, because we
think in terms of meters.
So there's a constant conflict
in terms of how we describe
elevation between science
and aviation.
If you're flying in a regular
airliner, how high are you
flying there?
You've heard the pilot come
on, ladies and gentlemen,
thanks for flying
United Airlines.
We've now reached our cruising
altitude of--
they'll say 35,000 feet, 37,000
feet, 34,000 feet.
So it varies, but let's
say 35,000 feet.
And you notice, you'll always
use feet for that.
And so that's going
to be what?
That's going be about
11 kilometers.
So that's going to
be about here.
Most of the time, when you're
flying back and forth across
this country in a commercial
airliner, you are just at the
bottom of the stratosphere.
You're just up in the
stratosphere slightly, but
then as soon as you begin to
descend down, you're back into
the troposphere, and you'll be
in the troposphere all the way
down to the surface.
Questions on that?
So try to develop a kind of a
sense for these heights--
and you may want to do it in
different unit systems,
because you want to connect it
with the way you live your
daily life, and that's not
always in the metric system.
I'd like to continue this
discussion a little bit.
You know the ocean
is layered, too.
If I draw the surface of the
ocean here, most of the ocean
has a depth of about
five kilometers.
This is particularly true in the
part of the ocean that's
called the Abyssal plane.
We'll be coming back to it later
in the course when we
talk about the ocean.
There are large parts of the
ocean that have a rather flat
bottom, and when it is flat like
that, usually it's about
five kilometers below
sea level.
And so on this scale,
that would be
about that depth below.
So the oceans typically are
about that depth on that kind
of a scale.
There is, however, some deeper
parts of the ocean, and they
are the so-called ocean
trenches, and the deepest one
is the Marianas Trench.
M-A-R-I-A-N-A-S trench.
And that goes down to about 11
kilometers, more than twice
that typical depth.
That's the deepest part
of the ocean.
And that on this scale--
well it's convenient, isn't it,
because that tropopause is
about as high as the deepest
part of the ocean is deep.
It's easy to remember-- easy
to remember that way.
What else can we use
to put this in
some kind of a context?
The Earth itself is layered.
If this is Earth.
Of course, you have the
core, which has an
inner and outer part.
You've got the mantle, and then
you've got a thin layer
of rocky material at the surface
that's called the
crust. And I just want to give
you a couple of numbers for
that thickness, so you can put
that, too, in the context of
these other numbers.
And the two numbers I have
here, the ocean crust--
when you're over the ocean and
then go down to the bottom and
find out how deep that rocky
crust layer is, it's typically
five to ten kilometers.
Continental crust, on
the other hand.
If you went to the center the
United States and measured how
deep that rocky crust is
there, it's deeper.
It can be 30 to 50
kilometers deep.
And then beneath that, you get
into the mantle, and of
course, you go down all the way,
eventually, to the center
of the Earth, which is-- the
radius of the Earth is 6,370
kilometers.
All these numbers-- every number
I've given you-- is
tiny compared to the full
radius of the Earth.
But they're comparable to each
other, which is why it's fun
to get them on the board
at the same time.
Questions on that?
All right.
I want to begin now a
different subject.
And the broad name for what
I'm about to do is called
Systems Analysis.
It's used in everything
from chemistry to
manufacturing to--
the basic systems analysis
is a study of a somewhat
complicated system that has
inputs and outputs.
Normally, you're looking at
a reservoir containing
something--
it might be water,
it might be spare
parts, it might be anything--
and then you're keeping track
of inputs and outputs and
trying to understand the
processes involved and how
those processes control
how much
you have in the reservoir.
So the experiment that I'll be
doing on Friday in class
upstairs is a simple little
experiment where we use a
water tank.
We put water in at certain rate,
we take water out at a
certain rate, and we try to
understand the equilibrium
states of that simple system.
I'm using it in this course as a
kind of metaphor for all the
different systems that are
important in atmosphere ocean
dynamics, including the heat
budget of the Earth, the CO2
budget of the atmosphere,
and so on and so on.
Almost everything we think about
in the atmosphere and
the ocean can be approached
using the simple ideas of
systems analysis.
The first concept that I want
to introduce in this
discussion is the concept
of residence time.
It's defined as the average
time, or the typical time,
that a particle--
or whatever the substance is--
spends in the reservoir.
So if I have a tank
of something--
maybe it's water, maybe it has
heat in it, whatever--
there are inputs.
There's a certain content.
And there's output.
The residence time can be
defined as the content divided
by the flux.
Now if this is in steady
state-- if
input equals output--
it doesn't matter which number
we use for the flux.
It could be the input flux or
the output flux, but it has
units of time as we'll see.
And if we know these two things,
the content and the
flux, we can quickly compute how
long a typical molecule,
or a typical amount of
heat, or whatever,
stays in that reservoir.
So let me do some examples,
because I think that will make
it clearest, if I just quickly
do some examples of this.
I'm going to start with
the hydrologic cycle.
So let's imagine that this is
the surface of the Earth.
There is precipitation falling
out of the atmosphere.
There is evaporation providing
water to the atmosphere, and
our system is the atmosphere
itself, and we'd like to
understand something about the
residence time of water vapor
in the Earth's atmosphere.
Well, here's what I know.
I can take a balloon with an
instrument under it, send that
up through the atmosphere,
measure the humidity at each
level, and compute the total
amount of water vapor in the
atmosphere.
We do that all the time.
And I'll give you a good round
number, a good average number,
for how much water vapor
is in the atmosphere.
But, I'm going to give it to
you in terms of a liquid
equivalent.
If I condensed out all of that
water vapor into a layer of
liquid, it would be
approximately
2.5 centimeters deep.
So walk outside today, imagine
you've converted all that
water vapor into a little liquid
layer, it's only going
to be that deep.
That would be the content.
That would be one way to
represent how much water vapor
is in the atmosphere.
Now you could multiply that
by the surface of the
Earth--surface area of the Earth
to get a volume, but I'm
going to leave it just as a
little layer depth as long as
I'm consistent with the units in
flux, I'm be OK with that.
So the other thing I need is
the average precipitation.
And that is approximately
1 meter per year.
So New Haven, Connecticut,
gets about 1.5
meters per year of rain.
That's quite a lot.
Certain desert areas
get almost none.
There are certain mountain top
areas in the tropics where you
may get seven or eight or nine
meters per year of rainfall.
But I'm going to give you
this as a typical
global average value.
What it says is that every year,
rainfall is equivalent
to about a meter of liquid
water depth.
So because these are both
depths, I can use them
directly to compute the
residence time.
So here it comes the residence
time is going to be-- now what
units shall I use?
They're incompatible
at the moment.
So let me keep it
in centimeters.
2.5 centimeters.
I'll convert this
to centimeters.
That will be 100 centimeters
in a meter.
And so that's going
to be 0.025--
oh this is centimeters
per year.
I've got to keep the
time unit in there.
The centimeters will cancel.
The year will come up top.
And the units on my residence
time will be years.
0.25 years, you can quickly
convert that to nine days.
Typical residence time for water
vapor in the Earth's
atmosphere is nine days.
Typically a molecule evaporates
from the surface,
knocks around up there for about
nine days, then gets
rained out and spends the time
then back on the Earth's
surface or in a lake or in the
ocean, something like that.
Question?
Yes.
STUDENT: Is the rate of
precipitation
and the rate of
evaporation equal?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So I'm going to assume that.
We know that that has to be true
over a fairly long period
of time, because the atmosphere
can't continue to
increase its water vapor or
decrease its water vapor.
You reach a steady state fairly
quickly in the Earth
system where you have that
kind of a balance.
And I'm assuming that here.
Now let me do the same
argument for
water in the ocean.
So label that argument water
in the atmosphere.
And now this will be
water in the ocean.
So here's the ocean, five
kilometers deep.
It's the same two processes,
by the way.
But now the precipitation
is a gain and the
evaporation is a loss.
So that's backwards from
what we had before.
But we're talking about a
different reservoir now.
Precipitation adds water vapor,
evaporation removes it.
This is going to
be really easy.
Because we were using equivalent
liquid depths over
here to do the calculation,
we're all set to do this one.
The flux--
so the content is going
to be the 5 kilometer
depth of the ocean.
So that's going to
be 5,000 meters.
And the flux is going to be
this precipitation, or
evaporation, because I'm going
to assume they're in balance.
So the flux is going to
be 1 meter per year.
And even I can do that math.
That gives me 5,000 years for
the residence time of a water
molecule in the ocean.
Is that clear?
So imagine that you're a
water vapor molecule.
You've just spent 5,000
years in the ocean.
You work your way up near the
surface, and then one
wonderful, bright sunny
day you evaporate.
And suddenly you're free.
You're a water vapor molecule
roaming around in the
atmosphere.
Nine days later, you're
back in the ocean for
another 5,000 years.
That's the way your life goes
if you are a water vapor
molecule on planet Earth.
So a big difference.
What's the real root?
Note the flux is the same.
It's the reservoir size that
makes a difference in those
two calculations.
We have time to do a couple
more of these.
Let me do oxygen in
the atmosphere.
So the source of oxygen in
the atmosphere will be
photosynthesis.
Green plants taking in CO2,
building their structures,
their biomass, putting off
oxygen into the atmosphere.
You can do this calculation
yourself, and we'll be doing
it next week.
But for right now I'm going
to give you the content.
And it's going to be 10
to the 15th tonnes.
And I'm going to spell tonnes
in a funny way--
T-O-N-N-E-S. That's
a metric ton.
A metric ton, by the way,
is defined as a thousand
kilograms. A metric ton is
a thousand kilograms.
The flux we can estimate
in a number of ways.
For one thing, we could put an
enclosure over a forest or
over a farmer's field and
measure how fast oxygen is
being released by the
green plants.
Or-- sorry, I forgot to give
you the other side of it.
Respiration is how
you lose oxygen.
And that's happening
right now.
Every time I breathe in, I'm
breathing in some oxygen, and
I'm not breathing
that much out.
So I'm actually losing oxygen
from the atmosphere
every time I breathe.
Every time a tree rots, you're
taking oxygen out of the
atmosphere and putting it back
into this degrading biomass.
And these things are
roughly in balance.
So I can use either
number here.
And the flux is approximately 10
to the 5th tonnes per year.
So the residence time is
very easy to compute.
It's going to be 10 to the
15th over 10 to the 5th.
That's going to be 10
to the 10th years.
That is about 10
billion years.
So residence time for oxygen in
the atmosphere, very long.
This--
be careful now, these
are rough estimates.
That is almost the
age of the Earth.
In fact, that's longer than
the age of the Earth.
So that's kind of a crazy
answer in a sense.
So you can't.
You can't have a residence time
longer than the reservoir
has even been there.
The point though is, these
are rough estimates.
But oxygen has a very
long residence time.
Once you get it into the
atmosphere it's going to stay
there for a very,
very long time.
But don't take that number
too literally.
It's done with some
crude estimates.
I want to do at least one more
here which is really important
for global warming.
And that is carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere.
Now again, the arrows
are about the same,
they're just reversed.
So photosynthesis takes CO2
out, and respiration and
oxidation you could say as well
puts it back into the
atmosphere.
The content of CO2 in
the atmosphere--
again this is a calculation
we'll be able to do for
ourselves next week.
But for now, I'll just
give you the answer.
It's about 2.3 times 10
to the ninth tonnes.
And the flux--
the rate at which it's going
back and forth between the
surface of the Earth and
the atmosphere--
is about 1.6 times 10 to the
eighth tonnes per year.
So the resonance time then is
going to be 2,300 times 10 to
the sixth over 160 times
10 to the sixth tonnes
and tonnes per year.
So I've just shifted decimal
places to line them up.
So I can do that to the
10 to the sixth.
And 2,300 divided
by 160 is 15.
So by this calculation,
the resonance
time is about 15 years.
Now this is also a questionable
number.
Because it turns out that some
of this is reversible.
In other words, what goes
out during winter
returns the next summer.
So what we've derived here is a
low value for the residence
time that is largely driven by
these seasonal, and therefore
reversible, fluxes.
If we summed over a year, the
average flux over a year would
be quite a bit smaller
than that.
And notice where that comes
into the calculation.
That'll give you a longer
residence time.
Maybe as long as 1,000 years.
So be very careful
with this one.
We've done a calculation
using actual measured
instantaneous fluxes.
And it's a valid number
in that context.
But if you averaged over a year,
where certain processes
cancel out, you could get
a much larger number for
residence time.
We're going to come back to this
because it's a key issue
with regard to global warming
and the buildup of CO2--
anthropogenic CO2--
in the Earth's atmosphere.